hi everyone and a very warm welcome to
the online event this humid house
appropriating nature for pleasure
this event is presented by the design
singapore council in partnership with
this human house
and supported by garden spider bay and
the national design center
it is also part of the national design
center's casting hope program lineup for
april and may this year
today's event accompanies the ongoing
exhibition garden dreaming at the
national design center
which showcases the development and
hopes for singapore as a city in nature
narrated through a series of interviews
with key figures shaping singapore's
architecture and urban scapes
the exhibition explores how innovation
is happening in landscaping and urban
greening locally
and encourages us to consider our very
own garden dreams for the future
further exploring the design potential
of local flora today's event will
feature john lim and his team from this
humid house an award-winning botanical
design studio
john is the founder of this humid house
and will be coming to you live from
within the garden dreaming exhibition
the studio will share about their design
approach and works the phenomena called
plant blindness
and the inspiration behind this humid
house's feature installation in garden
dreaming
and you will get to witness the
construction of this installation live
as part of this event
and with that let us now welcome jon on
screen sean please
hi everyone thanks for joining us
tonight i'm john
i'm the founder of this humid house and
uh come on
and here's my team of senior designers
we have francoise
this is carol and then there's karina
in front of us are some lovely
ingredients gathered from all over the
place
and we would like to thank gardens by
the bay for donating some of this
wonderful material that we have to work
with today
before i begin my presentation i'd like
to talk about what you see here on the
wall
of expanded mesh so the team can get
started
we have used the curvy branches from a
fallen plumaria tree
it's commonly known as frangipani to
make a nest or base from which the team
will add material to
why we call this human house um that's a
question i get the most actually
and uh well singapore as you know is hot
and humid it's not always the most
comfortable place um but we're trying to
make the best of it we're trying to make
beautiful things
um inspired by and in spite of the heat
uh so we have a focus on material that
strut that
thrives in this climate um
and uh i'd like to begin my presentation
with this quote from the poet
mary oliver every day i see or hear
something
that more or less kills me with the
light and i really like this quote
because it captures the essence of
why we do what we do i think everyone in
my team has an emotional connection with
nature
and i want to encourage all of you to
develop your own relationship with the
natural world
the larger aim of our sharing today is
really to
um highlight an awareness i would say so
that
there will be a greater consciousness in
uh protecting and conserving all these
all the amazing stuff around us
okay um so about a year ago um
in lockdown is when we started this our
own garden
um and it started off as something that
was
just an experimental garden but it's
something that made our team
incredibly hopeful in a very dark period
uh and what started off as experimental
is now producing at least 20
of what we use in all our products and
this is something that we are incredibly
proud of
we have begun a program to actively
acquire new material to cultivate grow
and use our work
what we try to do is really challenge
the perception of what
using tropical material might look like
so what you see um
on this slide is an arrangement of
largely tropical material but without
overt signifiers like monstera leaves or
birds of paradise
however the the inspiration of this
arrangement is actually
the the bird of paradise the bird
and what you see are these two pieces of
asahi palm fruit
that form the sweeping lines that take
on the appearance of a bird in flight
but we also don't want to be dogmatic
about um what we use so
it's not strictly limited to what's
tropical we use
material from all over and in fact a lot
of the material that you see here is
tropical subtropical and temperate um on
the right
is an arrangement in reddish and sunset
hues
and we really wanted to play with
texture you see a heliconia here that is
perhaps a familiar tropical shape
but it's also haliconia villageria which
is
slightly hairy its common name is
heliconia shikong which i
really love you know when we talk about
our work as a team we talk about form
volume color line texture and movement
which is really the same words that
you'd use to describe sculpture
and this is exactly it i think we really
take this very seriously and
think about what we do as as art
so a lot of our wedding clients
specifically ask
um can we do this or can we do that
and you know my response is it's your
wedding you can do whatever you want
and for example if it's your wedding you
can put turmeric or any kind of spice in
the table which is what you see here
on the table are these piles of turmeric
and we really love the color of turmeric
and we
which is very similar to marigold
actually we were trying to find a
substitute for marigold
um and arrived at turmeric um the
saturation
uh brings such intensity to the table
and uh you only need a little bit of it
to really make a punch
um you know we do a lot of weddings and
i think we are very aware that there's
an aspect of our work that is
anthropological
um when our work is involved in a
client's wedding
or celebration it's personal it becomes
a part of their personal history
but it's also part of a larger
conversation about the relationship
between plants
and culture so going back to this image
this is really about creating a hanging
cacophony of lightness and joy
so some of you might recognize this
image it's one of the most enduring
images that have come out of our studio
this is actually for the wedding of a
client who preferred greens over flowers
and in order to develop richness we
really focus on combining
an incredible variety of textural greens
and subtle whites
you know some of our clients get a bit
nervous when we introduce the idea of an
insulation that's not
full all the way through but as you can
see here the strategic voids and gaps
within the insulation are just as
important
as the areas of fullness
and on the right here is another
stair installation we really love the
challenge of
designing an installation around stairs
because whatever we create really needs
to respond to the architecture of the
stair
on the right something that might read a
little bit more tropical
but there's also a touch of whimsy with
the addition of vines
and the pond of aquatic plants that's at
the base of the stair
and this is another enduring image from
our studio
a kind of a swirling mass of heliconia
uh
they look like they have teeth it looks
like a scene from alfred hitchcock's
the birds and um it's swirling around a
mound of lotus roots and we've cut the
roots specifically to show
the beautiful section that is so
interesting and unique
and we were very insistent on getting
lotuses right out lotus roots brought it
right out of the mud and that's what you
see kind of slathered
on the roots
and here you see yam roots
um which we intentionally propped up
kind of precariously uh it kind of takes
the anthropomorphic shape
and surround and it's surrounded by
purple mushrooms
um that we dyed with purple vanda
orchids
and this is really a great example of
what we strive to do with looking at our
work as sculpture or
art
something a little more expansive this
is
an installation of klusha in vessels and
klusha is actually a very
prevalent um around the coastal regions
of singapore
uh it loves um mangrove or coastal areas
and uh this is this be paired with
unsodium orchids and
we really try to create like a movement
left to right right to left the depicted
dynamism and flow
and we've included this installation
because we wanted to talk about um
uh we use this as a platform to talk
about what we're gonna do here today
which is a wall installation
um this is also another wall sculpture
that we made
so the structure's actually made from a
live plant and a pot
that we then draped around and
a wall and then tied together certain
places
uh for structural integrity and what you
see is a combination of seaweed
and various like flowers that it's like
sandpaper fine petri volleyballers
uh and also um felica
which we use for kind of softness and it
was very important to
to us that this sculpture levitated off
the ground as though it was floating
as you can see we love using
unconventional material
like seaweed and i think this really
delighted our clients
and here's a hanging installation and if
you look
i'm not sure if you can see here but the
large bulk of this insulation
is from white bougainvillea and uh
you know white bougainvillea is
something that we see all around
we try to make it feel a little bit more
special by taking the time to strip it
of all its leaves
a lot of flores asked us how we're able
to use bougainvillea because it doesn't
really
survive as a cut flower what we do is we
actually
bag the root balls and use them in
installations and we actually
nurture them back to health again so
that they can be reused in future
insulations
okay um i'm gonna talk about plant
blindness what is plant plant blindness
and i think plant blindness is something
that
us and singaporeans especially suffer
from uh and it's really
only because of the incredible abundance
of green
greenness that surrounds us we're so
spoiled that we're
almost immune or desensitized uh to
what's around us
and i would really like to encourage
everyone to
develop curiosity around the plants that
they see
and develop a sensitivity to to to what
they're actually drawn to
and that's this is how i was sensitized
to what it was around us
um i identified qualities that
interested me
and i have to recommend a book um one
second
this is a my very old copy of
1001 plants in singapore it's published
by the national parks board
and it really is um in some ways has
been my bible
uh whenever i see something i like i try
to find it in here if not
i try to do a bit of research and uh
this has been incredibly helpful on my
journey
in understanding what's around us uh so
this is a clip
of our installation last year at the
esplanade cyan
um it's an insulation of bouncing
palm leaves and i like to talk about
this insulation
with reference to plant blindness you
know in singapore we're so spoiled by
the
variety and of palms around us and some
of these pumps we don't even realize
are just completely massive and the
the real aim here of of this
installation or part of the aim of
installation was to really bring these
ginormous leaves into an interior
environment so that people could
understand the scale and majesty of
these leaves
today today's installation is inspired
by
epiphytic communities um and the
specific reason why we're doing this is
really to get people to look up from our
from your phones our phones um if you
ridden uh if you've rode on the from
anywhere from the airport
into singapore you'll see rows like this
uh row of uh rain trees with thousands
of birds nest ferns
and in the elbow pits of these rain
trees
it's an incredibly majestic scene and it
never fails until a sense of wonder and
appreciation of the natural world
um this is also another book that i'd
like to plug it's
a guide to the common epithets and
mistletoes of singapore i believe
there's a more updated edition this is
spectacular
and if you if you ever needed to
identify
or know the names of anything that you
see um on these trees
this is the perfect book for you
okay um what i'd really like to
emphasize
as articulating
or in a way forcing yourself to
identify why you're drawn to certain
things and this has been incredibly
helpful for me in articulating why i've
been drawn to something i've
been able to identify the qualities that
i've been
drawn to and i think this has really
deepened my um
understanding of why i like what i like
and what i like and a point of view
today we are so pleased to have narelle
from design singapore joining us as we
create this installation
and she's also here to take your
questions narelle is the curator
of the garden dreaming exhibition right
here at the national design center
nurel hi honor hello hi
i've been sitting back here listening to
your talk and really enjoying it and the
beautiful images
thank you for your presentation and i've
also been enjoying seeing
the team from this humid house starting
to develop the installation
and we're at ndc in design singapore
we're really excited to
to have this installation joining the
garden dreaming exhibition
and having it through to the end of our
exhibition run to the end of may so
thank you for this
thank you and thank you for having us
we're so excited
okay on to this so we'll just um have a
casual discussion
as the team works on the installation
and also for
the benefit of our audience we'd love to
take your questions in
the q a module of zoom so please do add
your questions there
and we'll try and answer them as we go
so
john let me first ask you what does it
mean to be a botanical design studio as
opposed to a floral design studio
it's a really good question um well
i feel like we arrived at botanical
design studio for lack of
a better word um i felt like floral
design too didn't really
encapsulate everything that we did we
use a variety of material not just
flowers
um we've extended that to anything that
is perhaps or was living um
including like natural material like
rocks and wood
and all of those things also we have a
tremendous range or spectrum
of products and services so we apply
living media literally to anything from
a small bouquet to
landscape design and i felt like a
botanical design studio really
encapsulated that
also we have um an emphasis on design
thinking
um criticality and design design
as sort of a problem-solving approach
and for all these reasons
we called it a botanical design studio
that's exactly why we were keen to
collaborate with you
for this installation for the innovative
quality of the work that you're doing
which was
completely evident in the presentation
you gave just now
um so the inner that's what we tried to
capture in this exhibition garden
dreaming the innovative
potential of of marrying
vegetation with our urban environment
and the great potential that can come
from that
absolutely and i think that singapore
has been such a pioneer in doing this
and it's something that our team is
incredibly proud of so
[Music]
could you tell us about your design
process because i i think that's
probably
what everyone would love to know about
like how long does it take for you to
create an installation from
the r d to the completion what's your
thinking problem
i think we have a good slide there that
encapsulates what i'm gonna say
in fact maybe more comprehensively than
i remember it
okay so uh
our design process is not often linear
um
it's uh it can come from anything
i would say um but there are a lot of
factors involved
with design and i think uh this
diagram really encapsulated encapsulates
it so
i think there are there are a lot of
forces involved in
in the design direction um some of which
is like for example if we were designing
for a venue
uh or or a space or even
a piece of land for example um there's
the architecture there are proportions
um there's like the sequence through a
space
perhaps and even like the narrative that
we're trying to uh
get to there's a client their intentions
their desires their expectations and
then obviously there's constraints with
budgets
seasonality seasonality is a big one
you know i mean a lot of the times we're
designing for
uh events that are in you know in a
different period
and we really need to know what's
available then and design to that
um and also time you know a lot of times
with weddings and venues
events we don't have a lot of time
when you cut something off a stem it's
when the clock starts to tick
and so time is is really something that
we have to work with yeah uh and so
going back to design process um
it can really start from from anything
and so actually this is super relevant
to talk about the design process of how
we arrived at what we're doing today
and um we were so happy early on to to
have
gardens by the bay on board um until we
went on a recce
to gardens by the bay and this is the
very first thing that caught our eye
um it's incredible it's the
the flowers from a bromeliad um
and it's got these pink it's got this
pink sheath
that unveils like a shaft
it's a really incredible position isn't
it it's incredible and i think if you
um the camera could pick up on the
colors here um
it really like you know there's a bit of
an ultraviolet tinge to it
um and an avatar quality to this so we
really wanted to almost
build the colors around this what i
would call the star of this
of this piece um and then from then on
we knew that you know we wanted to
create something that was
that felt tropical as well so these
philodendron leaves came in
and in terms of a color palette we we
can never like
we can't we can't get the dragon fruit
overheads it's such an interesting fruit
a lot of people don't realize that
um dragon fruit come from a cacti
and the appearance of the dragon fruit
plant
looks like a lot of the epiphytes
that um grow all around singapore
and um so it's a game of like weird
association
that brought us to brought us here
basically
um and you know we have a weakness for
interesting fruit
um pineapples also from the brimley
family
um have this electric pink that we
really wanted to highlight
and of course these caladium watermelon
caladium
with these colors that look actually
fake
and so but it's a really nice um
marriage with a visual identity of the
exhibition as well
absolutely which is coral and what would
you describe the color as
yeah coral and deep green
deep green deep green yeah okay so
um a little bit about what we're doing
here
so out of this uh nest of plumaria
branches i think the team has
um correct me if i'm wrong team it looks
like uh
a real gesture like the first gesture
with palladium leaves
right and i think what's really
important is and i can see here that
um they tried to create this kind of
sense of uh scale by by putting the
small elements in the back and
coming up and radiating towards the
larger elements and they've done
something like a kind of a swirling
gesture
um i think it's it's it's important for
us to for something to have direction
but we're very conscious about not
making things appear too stylized
i think naturalism is really important
in our practice but
we're not tied to that as well and
sometimes the point is to subvert
naturalism
like i said this insulation is inspired
by empathetic
communities and empathetic habits but
this is you know caladiums are no way
epiphytic and for example what you see
here are actually the immature fruit
from the ramatan
which i which really looks like
chestnuts and so we're playing off um
all these associations
uh to create something that feels a
little bit more complex and
sophisticated
and i can see that there are some um
tubes of water
for some of the plants absolutely yeah
we've had so many questions already
coming in
and a couple of them are about how long
your installations tend to last but i
i guess it's going to depend on what
you're using sure absolutely uh
it really depends on how long it's
supposed to last so we've created
installations that you know have only
lasted like
10 to 15 minutes which is sometimes the
duration of the summarization
and with that we can take tremendous
risks we can use material
that will not last cut so we can cut
them and put them in and
not have a water source for them and and
we've done incredible work
um for events with that sort of a
duration for events that last
or if the installation is meant to last
longer
we know that for example cut cacti would
last a long time and sometimes even for
the duration of the month
so it really varies yeah we have a
variety of
techniques and mechanics to to
preserve the life of certain ingredients
for example all the caladium here
um are individually attached to water
tubes and that allows them to be placed
anywhere
for example this metallina magnifica
here which
i will get a close-up off later because
it's so incredible um it's bagged and
then they're root balls
and the caladium we got a little bit
lazy so we're just chucking them in
their pots
right into the installation um so
absolutely a variety of sources for them
uh i would i would expect that the
collidium will expire first
and um with this installation that it's
going to
be up for a couple weeks um what we're
going to do after this is maybe remove
the most sensitive material and organize
it
so that um whatever's whatever's remains
uh will last for a long period of time
thank you for that we look forward to
enjoying it in the national design
center gallery
so we're grateful to gardens by the bay
for
partnering this time with some of the
materials that you're using but
typically where do you source your
materials from we source our materials
from all over
um on the front line are our floral
suppliers and they get their material
anywhere from like anywhere around the
world a large chunk of the material
comes from
holland which is the center of um plural
trade
but a lot of other material and what we
are heading towards or
what we're trying to uh limit ourselves
to actually is regional material
um and a lot of this comes lovely
orchids
coming from taiwan a material that comes
the best material coming from
japan of course um malaysia
from thailand vietnam um from the region
and we are um partial to the to this
material because also
it gets trucked in with less carbon with
a smaller carbon footprint
also a lot of some of the material we
grow ourselves
and some of this material uh we are
foraged by our contractors
we have a lot of contacts uh with
contractors who have private land
landscape contractors and um some of
them actually allow us to forage freely
on their land
do you here's a question from the
audience do you ever work with invasive
species
uh absolutely so one of the things we
love using
is acacia um and acacia
is uh an incredibly invasive tree it has
weak
stems for branches and uh it's it's
always like a following hazard
um but acacia also um
[Music]
lasts a long time even out of water and
it's it's been a great
uh foliage for events
okay um let me
let me ask you we were just talking
about carbon footprint of imported
materials so
what's the in general is this type of
work
a sustainable practice i think obviously
by
by selecting materials locally you're
overcoming
a lot of that concern for sure did you
talk about that i would like to
emphasize that what we're doing is more
sustainable
um primarily as someone given life on
this earth as a human being
we are expending and using resources
so it's not in any way beneficial i
would say
what we're doing to the environment per
se but i think
with all the things that we do we are
really trying to
um close in on that carbon footprint and
make that as
as small as possible um be it avoiding
the use of like
plastics um avoiding the use of floral
foam for example which is
non-biodegradable um sourcing most of
the
material
most of our material locally and also
even using a lot of plants in our
exhibitions that we nurture back to
health
yeah and how's the appetite for local
plant materials
um i would hope that it's growing
um i think when we first started off
there wasn't really a consciousness or
desire to use that
and i think we've presented them in ways
that perhaps have
jolted people into seeing its potential
um for example
the use of bougainvillea which we use
quite extensively it's got this
beautiful
kind of papery light quality that we
want to emphasize in a lot of our work
um and we do that specifically by taking
the time to ship it of all its leaves
and a lot of the times you know clients
who said like no no i don't need
bougainvillea i'd be really shocked and
it's a
similarity to cherry blossoms at some
point
quite a few questions are coming in
about what you do with the materials
after an installation
do you research sure and you just
mentioned you can
rehabilitate some for sure so we do
there's a range of things we do with
them
um for some of our weddings we've
actually partnered with
refresh flowers and they're a non-profit
a group
that takes flowers that are used in
weddings
and then repurposes them for
charitable organizations people in
hospice
people in old folks homes and they do
wonderful work and it's led by
a friend olivia um we also
for large-scale weddings um put the
material
uh the living material back in in
compost it's
it's not organic compost it's industrial
landscape compost
um but that goes back to to compost
we are actually in the midst of
organizing
um a program where we're able to
actually
compost most of the material again it
won't be organic because
a lot of material we have uh
import a lot of important material
contains pesticides and we can't put
that in organic compost
so and we reuse a lot of
our material for example if we use like
branches for events
um it's shipped with its foliage and
then it's used for structure for example
and then obviously what we can't reuse
will go to the bin
yeah somebody has commented how
fantastic that is to you
so let me just uh change direction a
little bit i'd like to talk about your
background which is
actually in architecture you studied and
practiced architecture so how has that
influenced the way you approach your
work now
i think well architecture's in my blood
i mean like you know um i
i've i've lived it i breathed that like
i it's my first love
um and you know it's it's really i think
it's really taught me how to read a
space um a lot of the time
um in terms of the design process when
we were designing for event we would
do a site visit and i think a lot of the
times that the space would speak to us
it actually tells us how big something
needs to be to make a visual impact
or like the proportion
it tells us the proportion that an
installation needs to be for example
like for you know sometimes when you
have a tall narrow space
um the most predictable thing might be
to go upwards but sometimes
something super low actually helps to uh
exaggerate
the the height of the space so it really
depends so i think reading a space is
really important
at the same time too and understanding
of structure has been incredibly
important
i think uh with with my background um
we've really been quite fearless
in uh in hanging things and suspending
things off things and creating
um and understanding the idea of a
foundation
for structure and support um like like
this nest is
uh that's been helpful so i understand
that your team members actually come
from
quite a diverse range of backgrounds as
well from fine art
architecture floristry landscape design
so what's the
common language that binds you all
together i think we
we all have an emotional resonance with
the material that we work with
um there are some crying on this team
uh sometimes we when we make something
and it knows really made an impact
even but this is the best part even when
when a colleague makes something
we've actually wept at how beautiful
something
is uh and i think that that that really
ties
ties it all together that makes it
really worth it a lot of the the work
that we do
like 90 of the work we do is um sweat
and almost like blue collar labor uh
and the making part is actually a very
short ver very small component of
everything
that it takes to make something um and
you need
that emotional payload for it to even um
for it to to be worthwhile yeah
okay i want to swing back to the title
of
this session which is appropriating
nature for pleasure
why appropriating i think um i i chose
the word because
it really is a provocation i think uh a
lot of
i think we we have a lot to thank
ikebana for for example
ikebana is the japanese art of floor
arrangement and
um the translation for that in japanese
ikebana means uh
the way of flowers right which sounds
very natural
um but ikipana is like everything that
isn't natural
i mean it is taking things from nature
and putting them and gathering them in a
way that
um feels natural but really isn't
and there are a lot of techniques like
hibana for example um
splitting stems um putting things in
things
like they're to to arrive at a single
product so
i i i want to avoid this idea
that um when you make something or you
make a floral insulation that
somehow things need to feel natural
what you're really doing is
appropriating and manipulating
all this living material
as media to do something so i the word
appropriating
is is absolutely intentional uh and that
there's
incredible volition and intention in
what you're doing um
and that it's not always pretty um
i mean flowers are if you look at
the type of products and material that's
available today a lot is actually done
to flowers for example dyeing them
um preserving them um and and i would
say that that is really an extension of
appropriating living material
i would also like to equally emphasize
the part about pleasure
and i think that um a lot of the times
uh you know i think all of us in our own
practices our own personal journeys
really remember what it's like to fall
in love with an ingredient
or and then try to find something to do
with it and i think that's
incredibly important in um
and like like it's incredibly important
that we don't forget it i think
sometimes you're so busy
that that we lose that first touch with
that first love
so is there a connection here back to
the plant blindness that you were
talking about before
um absolutely i i think that uh
pomplin is i'm blind just curse everyone
i mean even even us
and uh it's taken years for example for
us to like really
see things um
it's it's funny for example rambutan
trees are actually all around singapore
um but a lot of people not a lot of
people actually know what formula comes
in
mangoes maybe a bit more often so
ramadan's maybe not so
um even like uh
this epithetic communities that i'm i'm
talking about like uh
you know i think so many times like i'll
be wild by what i see and then i
i'd be ex-friend and you know they'd be
they wouldn't be be looking at and when
i bring their attention to me like oh
wow that's really amazing
so i it really is about sensitizing
yourself to what's around you
yeah i tell you the questions are really
rolling in from that audience so i'm
going to try and get you some of these
um a quick um recap of what kind of i'm
just going to move these things around
so i can move
around the installation uh a little bit
better
okay yeah so somebody just wanted to
know again what kind of branches are you
using here
so the these branches are um plumeria
mary is commonly known as frenzy penny
and
uh we love them because well this
particular species of
plumeria is super curvaceous and like
if you can look at it looks like woolly
mammoth the
the the one thing about this species of
plamaria is that it's extremely weak
stem so if you see this
it snaps super easily so then a little
bit of voodoo
here um by adding the branches of
baffia so baffia is actually a very
common
uh shrub that's actually used to shield
um
garbage bin centers around because it
forms a very solid hedge
but um it also has incredibly strong
branches and that's actually the
internal structure
of this nest that that has actually
supported and pushed out
all of this stuff here um and we've
when we came to do a site visit neural i
think when we first saw this mess we
were like
yes we have to do a wall inspiration
because there's so many points that has
to
uh and we're gonna capitalize on that um
yeah also point to take we were very
thrilled to use
mary brown just because um if you can
see the
the lichen that's growing on on the
branches it has this kind of silver's
quality that
really matched the mesh and even though
we were creating uh
the idea of the nest was really to form
a kind of gesture that you know if you
took a pen and you like
kind of made multiple squiggle lines um
building a mask with lines it's what we
tried to do but we also wanted to like
kind of blend it to the background so
that
all this material would have a chance to
pop out and so it's also why we choose
area yeah do you make organic
installations for climate sensitive
people
have you ever been asked uh absolutely
so i think that's not
very difficult to achieve i think uh i
would say that
most of what we do in our garden
is raised without industrial pesticides
i wouldn't qualify as completely organic
but it is pretty close to there and if
we made an installation for you from our
garden
it might qualify as organic so sure
is your garden um is it on ground level
or is it
elevated it's on ground level yeah
what's the rarest plant you've got in
your garden
so this is uh this is a good question so
i recently acquired um
frankincense uh
yeah plant collector had a cutting from
africa
and i have it and i it's incredibly uh
fragrant um the bark produces the kind
of resin
um that when you scrape off it smells
just insanely amazing
okay
do you think there's this is another
audience question do you think that um
there is a high botanical design and
mainstream botanical design
and if there's a distinction um
would you make it when you're
positioning yourself um
yeah i would i would say there
definitely is a distinction um
and i think the distinction is mostly
aesthetic uh
and um it you know it's it's it's based
on so many factors i mean
like i think one of the most problematic
words that
for me is actually the word luxury um
well it means something it's beginning
to mean something so different these
days
for sure um and
like that is a problematic word and um i
i
it's interesting because a lot of our
clients um a lot of the weddings food
are
fairly elaborate um but i wouldn't call
the look of what we do
luxurious in a way i think it's very
interesting it's very full but it may
not be luxurious
so that's it really depends on on on on
the client
and and what what that means and with
aesthetics as well it's incredibly
subjective
um so i i wouldn't say for sure like if
i could answer that question
confidently yeah someone would like to
know
what made you leave architecture and
start this humid house and would you
expand into the architectural realm i
guess in a way you're doing that
through your landscape sure sure
so i will never stop being an architect
i think um i think that the way that i
think that what i'm what i'm drawn to
um i'm always looking at buildings um
i always have ideas in my back pocket i
get inspiration from architecture
so i don't feel i've ever left it um i'm
gonna just draw
attention to this here
it's the calabash tree sorry francoise
and we have to thank uh gardens by the
bay for it uh
it's flash is actually uh poisonous
um we have uh someone from the national
park sport say that
it's an old wives tale but people used
to take it so that they could get an
abortion
uh but i've we've chosen it because
number one it's super cute it has
this cannonball cartoonish-like quality
to it
and sometimes like uh we like to play
with the idea of like
cuteness um and i think you know the
canadian leaves themselves already take
on this kind of cartoonish quality
there are a lot of colors here that have
a kind of vibrant almost like um
cartoonish quality too so it made sense
to ask a request for this fruit as well
yeah beautiful perfect okay
are there any questions for the team oh
um
most of them are directed at you john
okay do you plan on expanding
the practice or conducting workshops
throughout the southeast asian
or asian region in general that would be
amazing
no plans yet but that would be amazing
yeah okay
okay how about are you
looking to expand into areas that are
not so humid
um actually we have some news coming up
that's uh
we'll release that when the time comes
to it yeah
first yes
so on your process and maybe this is a
one that the team could
help you answer is the design
drawn out beforehand is it a freestyle
drawing are you using
software to draw sure i think uh all of
us have become
very good scribblers so i think uh
oftentimes we will do a sketch for sure
and the initial sketch is always very
it's kept very loose very abstract um
it's almost like a gestural line
and the benefit of that really is to get
a sense of volume and scale
and that's the first move when we draw
and that and that came down with a pen
um i think the team is getting very well
versed with um
the ipad as well and drawing on the ipad
um
what is it what is the the tool the the
software that you use
procreate um when procreate you can use
brushes that
can introduce textures and give you the
kind of feathery quality
so i think every every um and for
example karina has incredibly detailed
drawings where like the flowers
articulated
and for me it's always a scribble and
then for francoise it's almost always
airy so everyone has their own style of
drawing
yeah um so there's no one way that
flowers are represented which is also an
interesting issue i mean architecture
representation is is such a huge issue
and i think
we're only scratching the surface of
what it means to do visualizations for
botanical information for example so
what do your clients like to see if
you've
you've been commissioned most clients
like full scale
photo quality renders and we don't
really have the capacity to do that nor
do i think it's
beneficial because it really ties our
hands in something that is so incredibly
subjective
and so we humbly offered them the
scribble of the sketch
so does an installation evolve as you're
making it 100 i think one of the key
qualities of everyone the team is that
uh we don't we're not precious we
we maybe purchased some ideas but when
we're presented with some material
and things are not working uh
it's time to change text and so
a lot of things evolve and that's also
why we don't want to be tied to a form
of representation that's overly
realistic because that ties us down some
things
for example for example i think uh we
were very thrilled by the idea of using
a lot of this
um uh epiphylon
but it really just wasn't it was really
appearing very dull against all these
branches and we've decided to really
reduce the amount of um
epiphylone that we're using so if this
was just done on the fly
um is caladium is not doing well we may
just get rid of it
or not i think it's getting
a different size um
yeah so i mean we really have to adapt
to
the realities of working with living
media
who influences your work and the the
person asking says
including sculptors landscapers
designers etc
i think there are almost too many to
mention i would say
we're very influenced by like fine art
sometimes i would send the team
uh even like a dance move which has an
odd gesture and i'm like i really like
that
so it's really from all over uh it can
be from photography furniture design so
i it's really too many to mention um
i think they're for sure uh you know
there's a whole
gamut of like florists and floral
designers that we've been drawn to
um constant spry for example was a real
pioneer spirit
she has an uh an ongoing exhibition now
the
at the garden museum in in in london um
there's also emily thompson in new york
who really expanded my ideas as to what
like
a vision for the topics could be like
somebody answered exactly that
okay for sure uh
and um and i think this is such an
exciting time for
um botanical and floral design the gates
are wide open
um like so many personalities are
allowed to
really shine true through and this is
this is the time where like
you know you really understand that
living media is now just
a form of like a medium for expression
basically
and in singapore is that equally true as
in other countries
i mean that that's um i guess this
sensitivity to the natural world is
something that we tried to draw out
in the garden dreaming exhibition and
the potentials that can come with
um integrating greenery into the urban
scape which for sure
so what i mean i think the singaporean
experience is incredibly interesting i
mean
i mean in some ways the amount of
greenery around us
is is really a result of like social and
environmental engineering
um and policies that favor that right
and so we are the beneficiaries of that
for example
um so the nature that we see around us
isn't exactly
in a hinterland it's not in a forest or
well there are protected areas but like
on the streets for example
so the nature that we see around it's
it's kind of like scripted but at the
same time
um given room to to look wild enough
that it gives the impression of like um
an untamed kind of uh uh spirit and we
can actually see that when you go to the
like you know book teemo or like any of
the
or even makimichi you can see like
nature kind of like um
unbounded and also you see wild wars
which which really adds to the
atmosphere
um but what i would say is that um
even like being in the army for example
for like for guys and like having to go
out to the jungles and experience that
firsthand
um is an incredibly valuable experience
um we're not
you know hold up in air conditioning
rooms for example i think that
interaction with like nature is just
like so important and so key
i'm not sure if i answer your question
yeah
well yeah we we think there's a uh
deepening sensitivity and
and increase along with the mandate the
new mandate of city and nature from end
parks there's definitely
i think from my point of view a growing
uh sensitivity towards a more
naturalized
nature in the city which i think a lot
of people really enjoyed during the
covert lockdown as well
as we saw the you know wilder weeds
growing and so on
absolutely yeah our team like we're just
delighted by what was um allowed to grow
during the period yeah a lot of people
want to know who
what you look for when you hire floral
designers
carol i i'd like i'd like you to answer
that yeah
okay everyone has to say one thing carol
um i think for me i always yeah my mic
is here
my first my first question would be um
like how ready they are with their hands
i tend to like always look for someone
who
comes up to me and says it goes i want
to make my hands or your hands that's
like
that's the most important and badly yeah
i think
facility with like even just like a
connection i like i asked them what do
you do with your hands and like even
cooking is helpful
um because well not only with your hands
but also like flavor profiles
understanding complexity all these
things are important
um friends of oz what would you what
would you say
what would you what do you look for when
you're hiring a floral designer
you have to come here because my mic is
here yeah
it's um first it's a lot of flexibility
i would say
it's all about i mean of course the eyes
but i always say uh it's
flexibility flexibility and really like
to like the challenge to like to always
get better
it's i mean i would say we i
yeah flexibility and for you
intelligence
as well she doesn't suffer false in
karina
um
[Music]
do you think the audience can hear do
you think is that
yeah okay and
[Music]
awareness yeah okay spatial intelligence
is that a thing
yeah yeah the room has to get
dirty that's a good one yeah
um yeah this is not this is not
glamorous
we're getting close to the end of the
session but there's so many questions
coming in so i've
honestly i don't know how to choose okay
um
let's see yeah
okay okay okay i'm gonna pop over here
okay there's a couple about how the team
works together sure so everyone seems to
be working very fluidly not needing to
talk to each other
oh yeah do you pre-plan what you're
doing or is it
you just have a rhythm together well i
feel like uh there's definitely a
synergy but this is
people working together almost every day
for years
and this is what you see here um but
i think even even at the start already i
mean like we have a good
sense for like uh uh
team dynamics right and what people
naturally quite
like fall into um and we've been very
i've been very blessed to have a team
that just like
comes together like a jigsaw puzzle like
you know um
we maybe i like i'm weak in some areas
and someone picks up after me
and someone will have a blind spot and
like you know and then the person is
that
for example um and then we are
relentless in our post-mortems and so
then we just
discussed as a team like how how can we
improve um why does this why do i feel
this way i don't even know why and then
we
try to pick it apart so um
yeah no this is like a this is a super
close uh situation
how will you all know when you've
reached the finishing point on this
installation
oh that's a that's actually one of the
best questions ever sometimes
the hardest thing to do is to stop
yeah i am always accused of putting too
much in
um it's interesting i always like the i
i was like playing with the the line
between
the feeling of too much it's like it's
like when you eat something that's very
rich
and it's like right in the line of like
oh this is amazing but and also a little
bit too much
um so i like my fearless really to like
toe that line
to a lot of people's annoyances like
stop stop stop uh
okay let's talk about this right now is
it time to stop one second
um
[Music]
i think we like if we had more time we'd
like go on refining it
like i i feel like um we haven't put
the most important element here which is
well we have one of that too i think
carol's
thinking about where she wants but the
second one um so i think in terms of
principles i can see where the team is
going look i've not really been paying
attention to what's been going on
but you can see here uh a real
concentration of pink elements here a
real grouping of them
okay a real grouping of the pink
elements here which are grouped for
emphasis so that from
farther back it makes a bit more of a
visual impact um there is a kind of a
nice blend
of the fluttering leaves of the
enthurian
of the caladium um and the antheriums
the leaf lily pad ethereums um you know
there and then there is like the
specific
elements that we want to show off like
the medellina here
and the bromelia flower um that's
sticking out here so i can see where the
team is going with this and there's
a real kind of sensitivity to the
original movement
of the branches that they've tried to
preserve um so
yeah absolutely we would if we had more
time continue
finding this but i already see the main
gestures here and they're working for me
so this this is uh this works
so an interesting question has the
covert crisis affected your approach and
the evolution of your work in any way
and do you think the industry will be
changed going forward
oh absolutely i think it really
quickened for us
uh a lot of uh the the main
kind of like uh the main drives or um
driving factors for why i started doing
what i was doing it was it's always been
my dream
to um grow the material that i'm using
and so kovitch is quickened that in a
way
and i think a lot of the values we had
were inherently
sustainable values and and um
kovitch is almost like uh really um
quickened that process for us
yeah there's still so many more
questions
and only a couple more minutes in our
closet but um perhaps if for
the questions we can't get to perhaps
you'll be um open to
it's like two seconds yeah go answering
them uh after this session for sure
um that's great so to our audience who
we
we can't answer your questions and
please um
do keep a lookout and we'll let you know
the answers a bit later
so we've got time for two more questions
being told
so how to choose how do you feel about
rewilding
and how do you balance manicured
stylized and
recreating as natural as possible and
talk about the relationship of human
humans with nature well that's like a
complex question
like can we take that in part how do you
feel about rewilding
um if i'm not wrong rewilding is is
allowing certain parts to be taken over
naturally by
nature without intervention is that is
that generally what it is or
um well according to one of our
interviewers in this scandal
it's um yes there's that but it's also
about strategic
maintenance so it's not um oh i see i
see
that area doesn't become a disamenity
yeah we are 100
for that i think things just look more
interesting um when they're given time
like room to grow i also understand the
practicalities of the national parks
board where
maintenance is a huge issue and the you
know like maintenance costs an issue so
you would then want to trim something
down
as much as possible so that it you know
the time the length between each
maintenance
uh would be lengthened um so i think a
good balance is important um but i am
absolutely for
rewilding if by that definition um
was there the second part to that
question oh i already answered it
about the relationship between humans
and nature
uh i guess i guess the point is how do
you encourage a deeper
relationship oh um
i think i think i mean just of what
we're the main thrust of what we're
trying to talk about today
is really about like just noticing stuff
right more and i think that's the
the first uh way of entry into
developing that relationship
um just noticing what's around you um
it's also the first way of developing a
better relationship with people
um noticing them so
seeing is perhaps the most important
tool you would have to
in your relationship with nature and and
then it's really being quite
intentional about it yeah get those
books
yes uh something maybe that's yeah
somebody did ask for the titles
i i also have a copy of 1001 that is
absolutely
that is like that's absolutely essential
i have to confess it's very
much less thumb through okay
okay let's um finish on this question
and hopefully we can um
encapsulate the the thinking behind this
installation and the exhibition as well
okay what would be a dream project for
you or a dream client
um i feel like i feel like we've um
we've had a lot of projects that
for example i think cyan last year at
the esplanade was just such a dream for
us like never thought that
we'd be doing something on that scale
um you know i've kept the idea of a
sarong rocker in my
in the back of my mind i thought i've
been always like weirdly interested in
these mechanisms throughout childhood or
you know
even my later years um and to be able to
use that on that scale was just like
incredible and like for that
um specifically for a southeast asian
audience where that mechanism perhaps is
like a common
uh and to use that in that exhibition
which is like
a total dream so i feel like a lot of
our dreams
have come true um and and and even
working with this material every day
sometimes i pinch myself that this is my
job
um well other days not so but um what
happens
uh when the going gets tough yeah it is
tiring
yeah yeah it's it's mental and physical
and emotional as you were saying earlier
mental physical emotional psychological
spiritual
um energy well that's the
way all good creative practices should
be
okay so i think we're wait i have to
support this dragon fruit so
um we couldn't find a
dragon fruit plant that was fruiting
so this is what i mean by appropriating
we we bought dragon fruit and we stuck
it on
dragon fruit stems that were not
fruiting
um so we're simulating what it is like
but it's also a little bit perverse that
we've done this
uh and it's also kind of jarring i mean
like we're you know like
like a lot very few people know what
where dragon fruit comes from
and what it looks like and and and we
really try to emphasize that
in this installation here yeah
okay i think we're i think i think we're
done
what do you think almost
and no one's ever really really happy
i think i think we should i think we
should have all of the this humid house
team okay
together to say farewell absolutely
yeah come um
thank you so much uh for being here with
us tonight
um you know it's such a pleasure that uh
our work gets the attention it does
never take it for granted
and we want to thank everyone uh for
their support we want to thank
design singapore the national design
center for their support i want to thank
gardens by the bay
for the donation of material and um
we feel very blessed to be doing what we
do
so thank you and it's been a great
pleasure for us to host you here
and thank you for this installation we
look forward to enjoying it in the
future thanks to all of the team
thank you to gardens by the bay and to
everyone thank you for your questions
that
flooded into the zoom q a module we'll
try and get to the rest of them
and do come down and check out the
installation
uh and the rest of the exhibition at the
national design center
thank you so much and i'll hand back to
felicia for the closing statement
thank you so much once again to john the
team from this humid house narelle and
to all of you for joining us today
if you would like to see this humid
house's installation in person and learn
more about singapore's growth from a
garden vision
do visit the garden dreaming exhibition
at the national design center which is
ongoing till 31st may
and before you go we would really
appreciate it if you could take some
time to share your feedback through a
quick survey by scanning the qr code you
see on the left
a link to the survey can also be found
in the zoom chat right about now
and if you'd like to find out more about
the upcoming programs the national
design
center has lined up under the april may
thematic of casting hope
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right this humid house will be joining
us for another online event in may
where they will demonstrate how to
create your very own botanical stylings
with 4-h materials
more details will be released on that
soon so do follow us on facebook and
instagram if you'd like to stay in the
loop
thank you once again for spending time
with us tonight and we hope to see you
at our future events
goodbye
you